do you protein couple receptors or GPCRs
for short our large family of membrane
embedded receptors with structural
features that have been preserved
through the course of evolution this
model represents the shared
architectural traits of GPCRs with the
extracellular n-terminus the protein
chain folds to form a bundle of seven
transmembrane alpha helixes
connected by three intracellular and
three extracellular loops with the
c-terminus reaching inside the cell
on the extracellular side the Gila sees
form a cavity where ligands such as
endorphins morphine or serotonin bind on
the intracellular side the receptor is
coupled to g-protein when the receptor
is activated by a ligand the g-protein
splits into parts which then activate
other proteins in the internal signal
transduction pathways
to create this model you will need to
download and print the template from PDB
101 you will also need scissors and tape
in this model the dotted lines are for
cutting and the solid black lines are
for folding the dark gray and the
semi-transparent gray areas will be
hidden in the final model
cut the seven paddle-shaped pieces along
the Dobbin lines
create the alpha helixes numbered 1
through 7 for each helix fold along the
solid lines to create a triangular prism
hide the dark gray flap inside
the tail ends of the paddles will
represent loops in the final model
connect each loop with the next helix by
matching and taping lowercase letters A
through F
now by following the thick blue line you
can see how the full polymer chain folds
into alpha helixes
connect Ulysses 1 & 2 by aligning the
semi-transparent gray area marked 1b
with a semi-transparent gray area marked
2 a matching the position of the diamond
symbols and taping them together notice
the first intracellular loop forming
connect Ulysses two and three by
aligning the areas to be and three a
matching the position of the circles
now you will notice the first
extracellular loop forming
in many GPCRs the seven helix bundle is
not perfectly symmetrical and helix four
is bound towards the outside of the
bundle form the intracellular loop
between helix 3 and the extracellular
one between HeLa C's 4 and 5 but let the
helix 4 dangle on the side
Connect Gila sees three and five by
lining area three b25 a matching the
position of the symbol with four
diamonds
connect Ulysses five and six by lining
areas by B and 6a matching the position
of the raindrop symbols
now you will notice the last
intracellular loop forming
Connect Gila sees six and seven by
aligning areas 6b and 7a matching the
position of the flower symbols now you
will notice the last extracellular loop
forming
finish the model by taping together
helix seven and one be sure to align the
semi-transparent gray area between 7b
and 1a and match the positions of the
Sun symbol
now you will notice the cavity at the
top that represents the ligand binding
site
you